minions eval I give to you master
my trembling subjects for a while no
that kept the reveal of my daughter's
seat well no more this time for you to
witness the true terror of the
Antichrist the horror of my office the
undeniable evil that will destroy what's
left of your souls
behold devil maggots
the fearsome face of darkness princess
of pestilence what's wrong with you this
isn't the Little Hell spawn I raised
letters I love you is this people Mary
you call Fluttershy and what's all this
talk of friendship and loving-kindness
friendship is magic daddy get me my wife
on the phone
hello Kim Kardashian what none how have
you done to our daughter look all I know
is that all that TV you've been showing
her has resulted in her spinning her
head I'm puking ecto cooler that's what
she's supposed to do she's the seed of
evil so I decided to show her some more
age-appropriate programming like My
Little Pony Care Bears Dora the Explorer
oh that's okay that's not too big and
Thomas the Tank Engine no ha no virtue
like this now take away your artificial
husband actually that's fine I think the
one you gave me is broken
our little girl back to normal like what
oh I created something long ago a
children's film so frightening and so
disturbed that no child could watch
without being scarred for life
bring me son of the mass
I got rid of it what I thought a bit too
scary for her so I've heard into the
human world servers is not involved you
do that to the human world mankind is
not ready for something so to brave god
help the poor soul comes across that
nightmare sadism don't worry I put it
somewhere where nobody would look well
if it's in a public garbage can it must
be where they're viewing
along the nostalgia critic guy remember
it so you don't have to we all remember
the mid nineties comedy the math one of
the first films to work in the growing
popularity of computer effects with the
more cartoony nature as opposed to
threatening it was a decent play with
the mass character for the kids and
carry straight man routine for the
adults and on top of that it made a lot
of money so much so that a sequel had
been in the works for eons it was
mentioned in interviews ten million
dollars for doing the mask to online
forums it was even a Nintendo Power
contest for it yeah then that's or not
to be a great prize wait years later for
a contest you forgot you enter to get
dragged to a set that has no Jim Carrey
no Cameron Diaz dog I think was friggin
dead by this point but hey at least we
have Randy front stream here's your
refund
where the man's kind of leaning towards
kids and adults some of the mask is most
definitely a kid's film even the
advertisements show pretty much nothing
but the dog and baby scenes but it's not
only a half a sequel without happy asses
of the original cast it's a downright
strange freaky little drive into
someone's poison to outlook as to what
family entertainment is it's a miserable
experience that I'm sure you want to see
me go through well if I'm going I'm
taking you with me run son of the mask
so we start in edge City where the first
film went on we enter a museum that
literally has the only cast member from
the last movie Ben's died and seriously
was it even worth getting him it's like
making ghostbusters 3 and the only cast
member you bring in is the lamp from
scene 22 though to be fair the lamp
would give a much more stunning
performance than Stein who's that ugly
guy that's Loki Norse god of mischief
and Loki's ultimate tool of mischief was
this the mask so just as he's talking
about Loki what a co-inky-dink
Loki himself appears played by Alan
Cumming who's almost as silly looking as
the Avengers Loki but not quite yes but
it's a good fake Wow and you're about to
see the number one problem with this
film what are you doing
this is one of many shit your pants
disturbing images granted anything
dismembering Ben Stein is usually a plus
but I'd rather be able to watch it as
opposed to run out of the theater in my
urine-soaked khakis
so the real mask is in the river just
outside a fringe city which is so
similar to edge city you'll be asking
yourself why the fuck didn't they just
keep it in edge City and is picked up by
the not dog from the first movie yet
looks so identical to him so that the
kids can see the trailer and say oh look
even the Jack Russell Terrier wanted
more money than they were willing to
shell out but thankfully they found
other performers who were willing to
take less like Jamie Kennedy I swear has
set his acting to permanent nasally
whine I know you're upset okay hold on
you know I can't run an apologize at the
same time and ask you one question good
all this stuff I can't go was this even
when he's talking normal
sounds like he's whining honey come here
because they say what does your daddy do
who's a pig on top of that he falls into
that common category of badly written
characters off the overreacting man
child who never listens never cares and
yet somehow gets an over understanding
bland under written hot chick why just
look at what goes through his mind when
somebody says baby stop right there
there's the poster for your movie
that'll get the kids coming in kids see
son of them is a family picture the baby
I'm just saying the baby right now
so while Jamie doesn't want to spend all
that time and attention on a kid Mikey
clearly fucking does for his dog
seriously even grommet doesn't have as
much dog related shit in his room we can
our first look at Wawa
rip Yosemite Sam Winkle actually that's
Bob Hoskins as Odin probably thankful
for his retirement whenever he pops this
movie yet that mask is close enough
misty for my thesis among the models
this is your mess and you will clean it
up Arthur king of the Britons your
knights of the round table shall have a
toss to make them an example in these
dark times who died dear o Lord cause
it's a good idea so Jamie works at an
animation studio which happens to be
hosting a Halloween party seeing how his
costume got ruined he grabs the mask his
dog found and I'll give you one sanity
tormenting guess what happens oh my god
like they make DNA syrup out of the
Jolly Green Giant and Conan O'Brien so
he torturously lightens up the party at
long last others arrived I thank God I'm
alive you too good to be true
yeah take my
I can't take my eyes off for you
so it'd be one thing if he stuck his STD
ridden dick in just one musical style
but this asshole decides to ruin not two
not three not four but five different
musical styles and each one is worse
than the last can you just tell
everybody to take five steps back away
from the wide-angle lens
good you can't believe show you the
choreography when you're faced ice
that's close to my calves rock you too
good oh yeah
can you seal the dances behind me aren't
they great looks like an alien horse
trying to French me at least the first
mask knew Jim Carrey's face was scary
enough from a distance it didn't need to
face hump the camera every chance of God
my god it's don't going I swear this
thing goes on for what feels like a
fucking eternity just keeps getting
worse and worse
hello this is vanilla I save this so
mutant ninja art she goes home gets in
bed with his wife and makes as Cuban
Pete will put it and it turns out the
next day the boss of the studio played
by Stephen right yeah I can't wait to
see the excitement he brings to the role
says he wants to make a cartoon series
based on his character this has
potential I mean not to be crass about
it with this guy this could be a
franchise character granted we don't
make a shitty sequel after the first one
I think we could do something with this
this has that spark I was looking for
yeah I'm talking about a cartoon series
that has Rob Paulsen as most of the
characters and we'll focus on slapstick
humor that should be funny but mostly
come off as just awkward short lived
cartoon series but his wife has some big
news too I think I might be pregnant
and you think Bella's pregnancy was
freaky take a look at this shit insides
would be powder but let's not ruin this
potentially unfunny joke it's a boy what
the big day comes and Jamie says hi to
his happy little accident I'm your dad
does Onan just live and remarkably
awkward segues
so Odin possesses the body of another
person and tells Loki that a child has
been born from the mask the baby and you
will find the mask
that's my letter size the cutest hey
where do you find these people is that
your dad come I blame him for that
shitty abomination of a third season
dad the entire third very darling come
on I'm going to show you an evil worse
than Hasbro
let's try this again we cut to a scene
where Loki is trying to find the baby
disguised as a creepy god damn
scary-looking concoction of hell
I mean guys seriously this is an
appealing image for kids it's like the
Statue of Liberty sneezed out the honey
nut cheerios beat so while Jamie reads a
book clearly the screenwriters didn't
read we find it's not so easy when
babies take care of babies
isn't that cute he almost fed him broken
glass a common everyday mistake of your
everyday likeable hero or even better
when the wife has to go out of town for
a week for a job
the unbelievably likeable way he takes
responsibility for his child okay let me
tell you in great detail why this scene
isn't funny you see okay seriously what
is with the imagery in this movie it's
fucking terrifying I mean I forget is
this the sixth or seventh level of hell
I haven't read Dante in a while but I
know this is in there he could have
forgotten something as horrifying as
this come on say dad dad mother hmm Oh
while we're on the subject of scaring
the shit out people you might be
wondering why is the baby still
concerned about scaring his father to
where his wide angle lens can't
obnoxiously stretch any further well
it's because he wants him thrown in a
mental hospital why I don't know I have
no friggin idea its explained about as
well as why the dog wants to kill the
baby oh yeah did I forget to mention
that the dog gets the mask looks like an
R crumb drawing of cancer and tries to
kill the baby now to its credit they
explain this a little bit by showing he
wants to be the center of attention
again but yeah this comes out of nowhere
- no build-up at all is the dog looking
at the baby here supposed to symbolize
that he doesn't like him is that when
you were trying to convey how would we
guess that everything else it shots so
weird and over-the-top that the only
thing being conveyed is the night
terrors you're gonna have tonight yeah
for a movie that doesn't know the
definition of the word subtle you don't
really explain these two things very
well the dog wants to get rid of the
baby
why two second image of a cartoon that
actually looks more realistic than the
effects you're throwing at us oh and I'm
not kidding the effects when the dog is
trying to get rid of the baby and the
baby super biryeo
widsom is some of the worst animation
you'll ever see I mean worse than baby
geniuses I know I can't take that back
but I'm standing by my words it looks
worse than baby geniuses come on Python
cartoons look more three-dimensional and
Laura knows this could benefit from some
British nudity and once again the images
are creepy they are so fucking creepy it
looks like every second it's um the
movie is trying to jump out and kill you
look at the baby's face it looks like
something Gollum threw up and animate it
oh and speaking of which here's another
fun image rather than have the eyes just
stretch out like normal cartoon eyes do
let's have them literally pop out of
their skulls leaving two black vacant
holes where the most expressive part of
the face should be hang this picture
over your baby's crib tonight baby big
shit it's scary it's really scary I mean
could this movie throw any more
horrendous imagery at us would you like
some thin chocolate
yeah I'm sorry I don't mean to call but
you're just the only decent good person
I can think of to solve this and I I
think my DVD is possessed Oh critic
there are a lot of bad movies out there
I assure you that doesn't necessarily
mean it's possessed but it's called son
of the mask and I just don't know son of
the mask hello hello mr. secret is it
safe
Santa Christ what are you doing
hold out your hand critic it's quite
cool maybe not this is the one dvd
forged in the fires of hell and now set
loose upon the world one of two things
must happen either you must return it to
its master or you must finish watching
it all the way through why don't you I
really want you to dinner I can please
take it there's not any more anecdotes
tend to be critic understand critic if
you gave me this DVD through me it would
wield a power to great and terrible to
imagine Wow because it's so evil it
would totally consume you know it would
just be really fun to use
indiscriminately no you have a bit of a
dark side critic you must finish this
DVD
I wish this pizza should have never come
to me so the wall who live to see such
times but that is not for us to decide
you were meant to find the DVD and
therefore you were meant to suffer meant
to go through the sort of incredible
psychological pain that no force on
earth could match that is a very
encouraging no that's not a very
encouraging thought in fact that's about
as far away from an encouraging thought
an encouraging thought could get well
that's all I got
here have gremlins thanks thanks a lot
let me know if you want plum or Lord of
the Rings anytime so Jamie try something
different for a change actually being a
good father by at the very least
changing the kid's diaper
why are you making me think about a baby
with three penises so Lukey finally
finds the baby and tries to force them
to tell him where the mask ends once
again you really gotta admire his
fashion sense I was being homage to one
kiss performed on st. Patrick's Day but
it's okay because the baby likes his dad
now yep right the fuck out of nowhere
again with no goddamn explanation and
Odin possesses Jamie's body to tell Loki
he's fed up I hereby stripped of your
immortal powers and forever banished
though he's a mortal now which doesn't
add up because the baby does all this
stuff and he survives it somehow but
what makes even less sense is Loki is
stripped of his powers just so he can
convince Odin literally in two scenes
later to give them back yeah just two
scenes later it's like a couple minutes
meaning there was no point to take the
powers away except to make the movie go
even longer because yeah that's what I
need this freakiest fuck movie to go
even longer let's celebrate with more
creepy ass imagery yes huh
god it's bad enough we have the
Schwarzenegger baby from Junior can you
imagine showing those two back-to-back
back
so look he takes the kid saying if he
doesn't get the mess back soon he's
keeping it this leads to a delightful
moment where Jamie thinks his wife
returned home is low-key and thus beats
the loving bejesus out of her baby big
chip so they find the mask and decide to
do a trade but wind you know it in the
less than three minutes of screen time
look he decides he likes the kid now it
wants to keep him forever thank you I've
come attached but the always popular
crotch shot get the mask out of his
hands and back onto Jamie honey I think
it's time we straight up
so they work their way into the Charlie
Sheen mobile actually to be fair that
car is fucking awesome and drive on over
to the final showdown
turn your wide-angle lens down you've
had a push to maximum since frame one no
why did they make a toy out of that it's
such a charming delightful a bitch I'm
sure kids would flocked it that's not
again so they decide they're evenly
matched and figured the best thing to do
is let the baby decide where he goes
Alvin your real dad come on wait I'm
just the mother so clearly I have no say
in this Oh
if I don't look at it again her people
don't look at the kid perfect I love you
so is CG mouth chooses his father again
the mother I guess wait no part in this
decision and we even get some family
bonding with Lukey and Odin I don't know
how things work in the god world but
you're his father he's your son and even
if you banished him he's still gonna be
your son
come on son let's go home okay
that's me
well gee if only Jamie Kennedy were
there in the Avengers I'm sure things
worth going over much better with Loki
if he was around there is nothing more
important entire universe a new
relationship
Jamie Kennedy Nordic God psychiatrist so
everything seems to be great now heck
Jamie even has a new idea for a TV show
baby in a dog competing for Dan's
attention I love this where did you get
the idea the idea just came to me yeah
that does sound like a huge hit TV show
doesn't it I did have this other dumb
idea about Japanese kids collecting
Pocket Monsters to defeat evil but this
this is really golf thank god the evil
is over
you would never hoped Horsham directed
the sell a poorly made movie that dived
into the mind of a serial killer well
person got it wrong this is the poorly
made movie that dies into the mind of a
serial killer it just forgot to mention
a serial killer part not only is the
movie horribly written awkwardly acted
filled with lame as hell of facts and
using way too much goddamn wide-angle
lens it's dairy scary scary scary scary
scary Terry's Gary Gary Gary
I feel unclean I mean I can destroy this
movie all I want but it will never get
rid of the images that it is played to
in here they will haunt me forever no
one should ever have to see the
terrifying terror that this movie
produced and they're not going to invite
oh my god it's playing again it's going
over and over and over I am a servant of
the secret fire wielder of the thumbs of
our Lord
Seiji I shall not fail you
how many times have you done this once
including now dear Game of Thrones Santa
Christ how's it going on there I'm not
bad at all you old up dad just picking
up a movie for my dog oh hello did you
leave Alena so still trying to take over
the world with that little Twitter
invention of your holiday tell me it's
not making people dumb tell me to call
everything seems to be in order here
give my best to the missus why I never
do he's so blasphemous come on honey
oh please please kill me it's the only
sensible thing to do it just showing me
this horrible horrible image is no
please
death is the only salvation what do you
think kiddo should I kill him nah I
think it's crueler to leave him alive
that's my girl you do your daddy proud
anyway they tried that before didn't go
over very well I'm gonna stash a crack I
remember it because it'll never go away
now behold one to hold parasites dense
darkness
that's Mike
you
say dad that mother